[Musique]
et
le reportage que je souhaite faire plus
que tout mais je n'ai pas encore réussi
j'ai bon espoir pour 2018 c'est d'aller
au yémen pour rendre compte de la
tragédie humanitaire que vivent les
yéménites
déjà les plus pauvres du moyen-orient le
yémen est la cible d'une campagne
militaire par une coalition dirigée par
l'arabie saoudite depuis qu'une
rébellion houti a chassé du pouvoir le
président a dit mais l'arabie saoudite
et la coalition contrôler l'espace
aérien et les manifestes de vol et donc
interdit l'entrée aux journalistes un
reportage que j'aimerais faire c'est un
rêve un peu fou ce serait de traverser
le continent africain mais vraiment de
son extrémité sud jusqu'au nord pour
aller à la rencontre des gens et voir
comment toute cette évolution
technologique et numérique les
influences eux aussi contribuent aussi à
améliorer leur qualité de vie a créé une
sorte de classe moyenne maintenant
qu'ils existent en afrique pour
rencontrer ces gens-là ils pour voir
comment ces technologies pourront sans
doute contribué à faire avancer à faire
développer le continent africain